at the highest levels of chess the clock
is considered a weapon and it's agreed
that nobody wields that weapon more
forcefully than yonda Palm Nashi nepo is
fast and he is feared for good reason
Nepal nashi's consistent Edge on the
clock proved to be a huge advantage in
his thrilling and dominant victory at
the 2022 feet a candidates tournament in
case you forgot and what proved to be a
huge dub in game one nepo worked the
clock to eventually get the better of
none other than dingley Ren oh yeah
that's his opponent in Kazakhstan some
elite players agonize over difficult
decisions look at the clock check the
clock I'm down on time cause I'm playing
nepo Yanda Palmer she doesn't agonize
over these problems instead he creates
them for his opponents he trusts his
intuition he plays quickly and he puts
the pressure and yonda palm Nashi has
zero plans of leaving Kazakhstan
empty-handed